there's Buckingham Palace We are
following dramatic new claims of
conflict inside Britain's royal family
The Guardian newspaper is detailing an
alleged physical altercation between
princess Harry and William that raises
new questions about their fractured
relationship the newspaper says the
report is based on Prince Harry's new
Memoir spare set to come out next week
Holly Williams is at Buckingham Palace
Holly good morning
good morning well some here in the UK
like and Harry and Megan's falling out
with the royal family to a soap opera
and say they are bored by it but this
new accusation simply cannot be ignored
it's alleged that Prince William
physically attacked his brother Prince
Harry during an argument about Harry's
wife Megan
and every single time I've tried to do
it privately there have been briefings
and leakings and planting of stories
against me and my wife in
an airing Sunday Harry claims he tried
to resolve things with his family behind
closed doors but alleges the palace used
the media against him and his wife Megan
the family motto is never complained
never explain but it's just a motto and
it doesn't really hold there's a lot of
complaining in a lot of explaining and
private being done in through leagues
through leaks ironically it's now part
of Harry's new book spare that's
apparently been leaked to a British
newspaper the guardian with a
sensational accusation that his brother
Prince William the heir to the British
throne physically assaulted his younger
sibling Harry claims William described
Megan as difficult rude and abrasive
according to the report before grabbing
his collar ripping his necklace and
knocking him to the floor Harry claims
he fell on a dog bowl which cracked
cutting his back he says William later
apologized Good Morning Britain breaking
news this morning an extraordinary
allegation from Prince Harry that he was
physically attacked by his brother
William during a row over Meghan Markle
in 2019 and Harry and Megan are
unpopular in the UK some here saying
they're sick of hearing the couple's
complaints in their Netflix series Harry
had already ready alleged that William
screamed at him in a meeting about the
couple's public roles it was terrifying
to have my brother Scream and Shout at
me but an alleged physical assault by a
senior member of the royal family in the
modern era is simply unprecedented Harry
reportedly claims in the leak from his
book that his father King Charles begged
his sons not to make his final years a
misery wouldn't your brother say to you
Harry how could you do this to me after
everything after everything we went
through wouldn't that be what he would
say so you probably say all sorts of
different things despite everything
that's happened in an interview with
Britain's ITV airing this Sunday Harry
apparently suggests he still wants to
reconcile with his family the door is
always open the board is in their Court
so far there's been no public reaction
from the palace and that's not
surprising they don't comment publicly
very much when Harry was asked during
that ITV interview about whether he'd
attend the coronation of his father King
Charles in may he said quote a lot could
happen between now and then back to you
guys in New York
Holly Williams in London thank you so
much I mean this is shocking news but
it's so sad these are brothers yeah and
you have to hope that there's some kind
of resolution because there's so much
pain on all sides absolutely yeah those
relationships are so important uh and I
guess by including it in the Memoir he's
saying this is not just normal Brothers
pushing each other's buttons and maybe
it gets physical time or two this is
something different it's it's bigger
than that when you're talking about
someone's wife you know I grew up in a
household with four boys and the the
easy response is Brothers fight but when
you're talking about at this level for
certain reasons
um it's tough but he said a lot could
happen between now and then hopefully
reconciliation can happen yeah because
that's what we want to see yeah
absolutely and you can see Prince
Harry's 60 Minutes interview with
Anderson Cooper this Sunday night right
here on CBS